today what it truly is is this is a  celebration of all of you in every  single way I may not even be considered  a part of this community  even though I like girls sometimes I  would never degrade the fight you have  all enjoyed the adversity but you have  all been through to truly be seen to be  heard or the struggles that you've been  through to love yourselves and to seek  that love from other people but honestly  I really really like you well I wanted  to be here and just show that I'm not  afraid and I could be out and proud and  me I just want to be integrated into the  community like everyone else have the  same rights as everyone else I felt like  it was important because this is a  really important moment in our gay  history so I wanted to make sure that I  was here for that I benefit directly  from from the the events that took place  and I wanted to pay my respects and just  feel the history